quand il fait très froid l'hiver
hydro québec n'a pas toujours la
puissance nécessaire pour répondre à la
demande dans ces périodes cette critique
la société d'état doit souvent importé
de l'électricité qui coûte très cher et
on finit tous par pays
l'objectif c'est de faire face aux
pointes hivernale hydro québec va donc
offrir aux clients qui le veulent bien
d'adhérer à un programme de tarification
dynamique
un tarif qui varie en fonction de la
demande
ses grignote pour nous aiderons québec
et ceux gagnant pour les clients qui
vont participer une tarification
dynamique
c'est simple hydro québec vous promet de
réaliser des économies sur votre facture
globale
si durant des heures de poing dans les
grands froids vous changer
significativement votre consommation
d'électricité faut savoir que la société
d'état a déjà testé la tarification
dynamique dans un projet pilote il ya
environ 10 ans et les résultats étaient
plus ou moins concluants les
participants ont bien modifier leurs
habitudes en ce qui concerne de la
vaisselle la laveuse ou la sécheuse
par contre il ya eu très peu de
changements ce qui concerne l'eau chaude
ou le chauffage
au final les clients ont vu leur facture
annuelle baissé d'environ 1% ce qui à
l'époque voulait dire à peu près 13
dollars de son côté hydro québec
estimait que le tarif variable du projet
pilote aurait pu lui permettre
d'économiser une vingtaine de mégawatts
ce qui équivaut à environ 10 éoliennes
ce qui est assez marginal
[Musique]